the Teletubbies and stuff like that and
the the cartoons are really kind of more
geared towards younger people and when
you're talking about like the
um
the bad guys that that Batman was
fighting the more complex characters
like Mr Freeze and stuff if you look at
your average uh
uh environmentalist you know they have a
similar Outlook to
uh Thanos you know get there's too many
people there's we have to get rid of
people we have to have uh population go
down we have to control the population
and if you know there's not enough
resources on Earth and we blah blah blah
your average socialist uh
environmentalist is just Thanos without
the the the the glove is this Thanos
from the movie he actually wanted to
kill half the people for population
control he wanted to kill half of the
people in the in the universe